good evening David and I are very
pleased to be presenting the Oscars for
both documentary short subjects a
live-action short film the nominees in
these categories have made wonderful
unique movies under the added
constraints of a shorter running time we
hope that many of you will be curious
enough to seek out these big films in
small packages our nominees for
documentaries soared short subjects all
captures decisive moments when lives are
changed those who make these films are
heroic and the stories they tell are
powerful here are the nominees for Best
Documentary Short subject extremists
dan Kraus four point one miles
Daphne Matta rocky Jo's violin kahani
Cooperman and Raphael and a Hammond
Hasani my homeland Marcel met Rosie Sun
and Stephen Ellis the white helmet
Orlando Vaughn is Adele and Johanna next
acara
and the Oscar goes to the White House
you
this is the first Oscar and second
nomination for Orlando van icinga and
Johanna not the bedrock
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
however relativist
and okay well Thank You Tube Academy for
this huge honor to all of our teams of
course to announce exile work families
for supporting us with this film but
most of all thank you to the white
helmets
sadly Ryad Sallah the head of the white
helmet is not able to join us tonight
we're very short statement from that
we'd like to share with you we're so
grateful that this film has highlighted
I'll work to the world our organization
is guided by a verse from the Quran to
save one life is to save all of humanity
we have saved more than 82,000 Syrian
lives and by anyone here who hears me to
work on the side of life to stop the
bloodshed in Syria and around the world
it's very easy to these guys to feel
they're forgotten this Wars been going
on for six years if everyone could just
stand up and remind them that we all
care that this war ends as quickly as
possible
thank you